Michael Jordan and Isaiah Thomas do not  like each other in case you don't know  the story it was 1991 Eastern Conference  Finals uh Jordan blows out Isaiah's  pistons and Isaiah walks off the court  without shaking Jordan's hand Jordan  gets pissed off and he's carried that  Grudge with him for I don't know however  many years it's been since then what I  love about this story though is Magic  Johnson  Magic Johnson then takes it upon himself  to say you know what  I'm gonna have to be the one that brings  him together and it just makes you think  of are you the leader who sees a problem  and instead of letting everybody else  complain about it and blame each other  about it are you gonna be the person who  steps up and say you know what  I'm gonna fix it  I am the only one who can fix it and I'm  going to do something about it  is that you